today on the matt well show beyonce just
released a new album and as always the
media tells us that it is a work
of staggering artistic genius and that's
all anyone is allowed to say about
beyonce of course in reality though
she's a mediocre pop star but what what
does it say about our culture that these
are the artists we elevate
and the art that we hail as especially
significant and beautiful we'll talk
about that plus five headlines including
riots continuing in portland even though
we were assured that riots would end as
soon as the feds left yet
they didn't so what's up with that in
our daily cancellation i am forced to
cancel
tommy laron um she has left me no choice
i must do it
and that's all coming up on the show
today but first
the show today is brought to you by rad
power bikes listen it's summer time we
all want to get out of the house
there's no better no more fun way to do
it
than with an electric bike you take my
word for it actually don't take my word
for it try it for yourself that's even
better
whether you want a new way to commute or
to get around the city
you want to get out in nature even with
your kids in tow whatever your purposes
are
why ever you're getting out you've got
to try
rad power bikes it's a cross between a
traditional bike and a moped but it
doesn't require a special driver's
license like a moped would
you go up to 20 miles per hour without
pedaling so you get out
get about you can get wherever you want
to go without getting all sweaty
and uh they're great for commuting
they're great for going out in the trail
for hauling groceries
as i said transporting kids on the back
you could do that too unlike other
e-bikes
they're actually affordable plus to show
appreciation for those that serve us rad
power bikes is offering 100
off all e-bike purchases for active
ex-military first responders teachers
and
students the thing i love about rad
power bikes the most is that
it's practical and also fun that's the
best of both worlds because
as an adult especially like to have fun
but there needs to be an element of
practicality to it as well and you can
get that with rad power bikes
now uh listen to this part rad power
bikes offers flexible financing for as
low as zero percent apr and right now
as a limited time offer you can get a
free accessory with the purchase of a
bike that's right get a free gift of up
to 100
off and free shipping to the lower 48
states you can get all of that
uh special offer but you got to text the
word bike to 64 000
that's bike to 64 000 text bike bike
to 64 000.
okay now
if you happen to hear collective shouts
of near
orgasmic adulation and delight at going
from c to signing
shining c last friday it was because
beyonce released a new album
and the screams were coming from music
critics and others in media
who want us to know that black is king
the new album
is quite possibly the greatest artistic
achievement of all time
equaled only by beyonce's other albums
together comprising a catalog of music
so breathtaking and awe-inspiring that
beethoven
if he wasn't deaf and also dead would be
plunged into despair upon realizing that
he could never hope to produce anything
as heart-wrenchingly beautiful as what
beyonce can make
um this this latest offering from
beyonce
released as a visual album on disney
plus their streaming service
as a companion piece to last year's
rather abysmal lion king remake
and also as a traditional album on
itunes is according to npr
a quote sumptuous search for divine
identity that quote resonates deeply
critics of the new york times were
beside themselves with joy using words
like
overwhelming and extravaganza and
comparing i'm not making this up
comparing beyonce to quote the rising
sun
the av club exclaimed that the pop album
inspired by disney cartoon is
an unfettered celebration mashable
said that beyonce is quote the only
artist to exist at her level
she is in their words quote magical
phrases like a tribute to her artistry
and supreme black art have been
wielded by these gobsmacked critics
everyone seems to agree
that black is king is a masterpiece
coincidentally we were also told that
her last album was a masterpiece
and the one before that and the one
before that and
all the rest of them all the way back to
her first album in 2003
which was also a masterpiece the only
possible exception was her
fifth album her eponymous fifth album
which was merely according to one critic
close to a masterpiece well i guess even
the queen has her off days i suppose
the only thing more effusive than the
praise that beyonce receives for her
music is the praise she receives for
simply existing
an article in w magazine written to
defend her against charges that she
doesn't write her own music
insists that pop star is quote an
exceptional human being
at everything she tries and by the way
the defense is that she doesn't write
her own music
but she is involved okay and truly it
takes an exceptional woman
to be involved in the song that she is
singing
another article calls beyonce an
irreplaceable force for inspiring change
elsewhere she's called quote the
greatest artist of the decade and
from a more timeless perspective she has
also been routinely called
a goddess the point is clear
um beyonce is an extraordinary artist
an extraordinary woman an extraordinary
human
and everything she does is equally as
extraordinary
this is this is american society's
official beyonce position
and dissent will not be tolerated those
few who do dare to commit the
unspeakable sin of failing to squeal
with delight every time beyonce does or
says anything at all
are we are told racist uh fellow singer
lana del rey was
was forced to defend herself against
racism charges after offering
mild criticism of beyonce a little while
ago on instagram
because according to the worshipful
masses you could not possibly have
any reason to dislike any aspect of
beyonce or her music
unless you simply hate all black people
in general
and and and uh and that is the only
explanation we are told
or maybe not let me offer another
potential reason to be slightly less
enthused about beyonce
than the reverend critics already
mentioned are
she's not that great she is not a
staggering genius
no matter how often we are instructed to
view her that way
for better or worse her music is rather
run-of-the-mill pop fair
it isn't particularly innovative it
certainly isn't insightful
one of the most popular songs on her
latest album um a jaw-dropping track and
the best on the album according to
billboard
is called mood for eva the number four
eva mood forever
and the lyrics are about what you'd
expect from a song that uses a number in
place of a word
here's here's beyonce's opening verse
i'll just give you i'm not going to sing
it here are the lyrics
i know my enemies prey on me so pray for
me
tick tick weight on it i'm keeping down
my body count
i'm finessing like a trap bounce a trap
bounce
because every day above ground is a
blessing i done leveled up now view
panoramic
none of my fears can't go where i'm
headed had to cut them loose
now i'm loose break the levee yeah i'm
about to flood on them
flood on a sinner the rain and thunder
gone fall
gomen tumbo no no center you can't dim
my light
that song has 14 credited writers
now admittedly it's practically vergil
in comparison to some of her past lyrics
uh bow down bow bow down
bow bow down bow down from the song bow
down comes to mind
but it's a it's a it's very hard to see
how this rises to the level of
masterpiece
you could argue that her music
especially on this most recent album
is judged as much by the accompanying
visuals as by the songs themselves
fine but the visuals are fairly standard
for modern music videos there's nothing
very special about it
she's a good dancer certainly but even
as a dancer she isn't doing anything
that other young pop divas can't do
michael jackson was a genius dancer
because he redefined the art form
and moved in ways that seemed almost
physically impossible
he reinvented dancing beyonce is not
doing that she isn't doing anything
remarkable she delivers a product that
is visually and audibly a perfectly
acceptable entry
into an already existent genre her
dancing and singing are pretty good
her lyrics and the messages they contain
generally straddle the line between
vapid and repugnant in other words she
makes pop music
nothing less certainly nothing more
now i wish i could say that this attempt
to
turn the single ladies singer into pop's
version of michelangelo
was merely dumb and annoying it is both
of those things of course but it's also
more toxic than that
you can judge a culture in many ways by
its most celebrated art
and the people within a culture will
judge themselves
in many ways through the same lens our
art is the story that we tell
about ourselves to ourselves it's how we
grapple
with the problem of existence it's how
we search for deeper truths there's a
reason why art and religion have been
inextricably inextricably tied since the
dawn of civilization
speaking of michelangelo the people of
the 16th century
in italy they could step into the
sistine chapel look up
in wonder and feel themselves and their
spirits drawn
into a beauty that was and still is
truly transcendent
this is quite different from the
experience modern americans have when
they listen to beyonce sing
can you eat my skittles it's the
sweetest in the middle
from the song blow in 2013. beyonce's
music
like most pop music is diverting and
catchy at its very best at its worst
it's so ugly and stupid as to induce
despair
the point is not that our culture has no
great art that's not my point
musicians of the last several decades
have given us many authentic
masterpieces and geniuses and other
mediums like film and television
have produced art that will stand the
test of time for sure but
the art we choose to elevate the highest
and praise the loudest
is the art that will influence us and
especially our children
the most and define us define our era
so i suppose it's appropriate that
beyonce claims that honor as the
defining artist
because ours is an era that is loud and
extravagant
but empty at its core and not as
impressive as it appears on the surface
like beyonce so if beyonce is our queen
our empress then someone has to say
the empress has no clothes literally
much of the time let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
so move on to our headlines here um i
want to tell you about
our friends over at bambi you know
when running a business hr issues can
really kill you uh it's it's one of the
things that every business owner i hear
some business owners all the time this
is one of the things especially nowadays
um it's gonna cause a lot of problems
for your wrongful termination suits
minimum wage requirements labor
regulations just a lot of
a lot of red tape you don't know exactly
a lot of things you have to navigate
and hr manager salaries are not cheap
either an average of seventy thousand
dollars a year
bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e-e was created
specifically for small businesses you
can get a dedicated hr manager
uh craft hr policy maintain your
compliance navigate all the red tape do
everything you need to do
all for just 99 a month so compare 99 a
month to 70 000 a year
all right your dedicated hr manager is
available by phone email reads
real-time chat whatever it is this is
your dedicated person
hr manager from onboarding to
terminations they customize your
policies to fit your business
and they help you manage uh your
employees day-to-day all for just 99
a month month to month no hidden fees
cancel any time
uh there's just no reason i can see if
you're a small business to not
uh look into this go to bambi.com walsh
right now to schedule your free hr audit
that's bambi.com walsh spelled
b-a-m-b-e-e
dot com slash walsh all right remember
uh when we were told that the rioting in
portland
was all in response to the presence of
federal agents even though it started
before the federal agents got there
it was still because of them somehow it
was their fault and that as soon as they
left the rioting would go away that's
what we were told
of course
many problems with that logic from the
beginning you would have to have the iq
of
a spatula believed it to begin with but
um if you do have the iq
of a of a kitchen utensil and you
actually believed that the writing would
stop because law enforcement left
then this footage will be very shocking
to you watch
well you can see there that's that's
rioters in portland
after feds had already left trying to
burn down a police precinct
so i i not very peaceful
not very peaceful um that's not not
exactly joining hands around a campfire
singing kumbaya now there was a fire but
it wasn't a campfire
so uh no i i i think it it turns out
that when you have a lawless mob of
criminals and you do less
to enforce the law you end up with more
crime
crazy crazy how that works really
shocking number two we begin um
or not begin we we go now to a news
story
this is a new story that doesn't really
exist
i guess the news here is that there is
not any news
um and i think in this case the fact
that there is no news
is news indeed i'm starting to confuse
myself now here's what i'm talking about
you may remember the story from about
six weeks ago a woman by the name of
althea bernstein
in madison wisconsin called the police
late at night claiming that she had just
been attacked by a gang of racist white
men
and she said that this roving gang of
white supremacists they were all wearing
hawaiian
shirts they were like frat boys she said
they came to her at a stop
light they sprayed her in the face with
lighter fluid and then they threw a
lighter into her car
and set her on fire her face was
actually on fire
that's what she said now this was huge
news when it happened it was reported
everywhere i heard it all over the place
meghan markle even reached out to
bernstein to express her
condolences it was a
a a pretty big deal and sure
i mean if something like that happens of
course it's a big deal you've got a
group of murderous bigots patrolling the
streets of an american city
literally trying to burn women alive in
the middle of the street
that that's a big deal but then and this
brings us to our
update today um then there was nothing
it was six weeks ago and it was a big
story for a few days
and then it just disappeared madison
police said they were investigating the
attack then the feds got involved and
um you know this is all good because it
happened
at an intersection in a major city so
there has to be cameras all over the
place and witnesses
surely these flame throwing racists are
on tape
someone else must have seen them also i
mean it should be pretty easy to track
them down
yet six weeks later we've heard nothing
about this case
nothing not a word
it really makes you think in fact i went
to google and i searched for althea
althea bernstein i searched her name
story news stories from the last week
zero zero reporting not
one story on the entire internet
was published in the last week about
this case isn't that pretty strange i
mean it's almost like this story
vanished into thin air and so did the
white boys with the lighter fluid and
the lighter that somehow could stay lit
when they threw it
now let's just imagine crazy thought
crazy thought but let's just thought
experiment
let's imagine that possibly the white
boys vanished into thin air
because and nobody ever noticed them
except for her
and they weren't recorded by any camera
as far as we know
let's imagine again hypothetically that
all of that is the case
because they don't exist pretty easy to
vanish when you never existed to begin
with
so let's say wild theory none of this
ever happened
it's yet another hate crime hoax on that
theory the cops would would of course
know that it's bs and they would know
right away i mean they would know
probably from the moment they hear it
but all they'd have to do is look at the
surrounding video footage
talk to some people that were in the
area and they would know right away this
just this
simply didn't happen
um and yet i mean again on this theory
they're just not saying anything about
it
hoping we all forget and the sad thing
is
that plan seems to actually be working
just fine
but it's scary to think that we've
arrived at this point where a person can
invent a hate crime
file a false police report and just get
away with it
no penalty whatsoever because the police
are too afraid to tell the public that
it was all a load of horse manure
that's a scary thought number three um
you know i have to throw this in here
credit words do uh i uh i am capable of
of
you know of giving credit sometimes i
mean i i
you know that i i criticize trump
sometimes and i especially criticize
his tweeting uh but sometimes i have to
admit even
that he puts out one hell of a great
tweet and this is one of those times so
like i said credit where i just want to
show you this tweet because i thought it
was so good
and i really just i wanted to give all
the credit to donald trump on this one
um here's the tweet from a man he says
uh look at this here's the
here's the quote he says um cities
across the nation that are run by
democrats are in shambles
matt walsh yeah he seems to be quoting
someone there someone
someone who was on tucker last night he
was watching tucker and he was quoting
i don't know i'm not sure who that guy
is really but brilliant point
that man whoever that is i think we can
all agree has
the powers of insight that would rival
aristotle
um so a great job by trump putting that
that quote out there that's all he wants
really like i said this is really about
giving donald trump credit
for a great tweet number four it was
just announced that uh the live
adaptation of mulan
will go straight to disney's streaming
service
and uh right when you're done after
you're done watching black is king you
can go and watch mulan
except it's gonna cost you thirty
dollars it's gonna come out in a few
weeks
thirty dollars plus the subscriptions
you pay for the subscription at disney
plus and they're gonna charge you an
extra 30 bucks to see this
and this is all i'm gonna say if you pay
thirty dollars to watch a lifeless
pointless rehashed remake of a disney
cartoon that you've already seen
i don't think it's too much to
suggest that you should lose your
citizenship rights
and i don't even say that ironically i i
would with all sincerity
support a policy that stripped you of
your constitutional rights all of them
for paying 30
to watch the mulan remake
number five um just a policy proposal
i'm throwing out there if any if anyone
wants to run with it number five finally
oprah winfrey who we should note is
worth two billion dollars
spoke out this week against the scourge
of white privilege
um oprah with her two billion dollars is
very concerned
that white people in trailer parks
wearing goodwill hand-me-downs
might be a little bit too privileged and
here's part of her discussion
on that subject there are white people
who are not as powerful as
the system of white people the caste
system that's been put in place
but they still no matter where they are
on the wrong or the ladder of success
they still have their whiteness
i just love how she's having this
discussion about white privilege
while sitting in a room that looks like
that room from the last matrix film
she's literally controlling the whole
matrix from that room
and yet complaining about other people
having privilege this this is weapons
grade irony right here
i i really know what i really like to
imagine is her
shouting something like white people are
too privileged and then
walking directly into her 98 room
mansion
tossing her 40 000 coat made of the
skins of albino seals
at her butler you know petting her
siberian tiger
and then just heading to her golden
crusted bathtub filled with champagne
and caviar and jumping in
um that's how i imagine that oprah
winfrey must live
but yeah you know really really rick and
maureen
down the street driving their minivan to
home depot on a saturday stopping at
ruby tuesdays for their
uh early afternoon special on the way
back those are the people that are
privileged not oprah winfrey
those people sure yeah we make a joke
out of it but
this it's because it is a joke you see
the farce that this
that this white privilege concept uh
has become that now even
the richest woman in america uh one of
the richest in the world
is complaining about other people having
privilege
it's just fantastic okay speaking of uh
fantastic now we're gonna go to our
daily cancellation
um and for our daily cancellation today
i'm afraid that i i have to
cancel tommy larin now i used to work
with tommy full disclosure we were both
over at the blaze
for a while i mean we were different we
were in different states so it's not
like we we collaborated closely together
but i went on our show a few times and
it was great
um and so this cancellation is nothing
personal
but it must be done because nobody
escapes
the wrathful gaze of the daily
cancellation you know that by now even
my wife and kids don't
nobody no mortal even immortals okay
they aren't necessarily off the hook
so either has cancelled for a lengthy
psa that she
she published yesterday a 14-minute
minute video criticizing men
talking about why men are terrible and
why her own relationship problems are
the fault
of men and men are as she said trash
uh take a listen these women range
in every body type and every everything
they're all successful
they're all intelligent they're all good
people but if all of these women
including myself
are having issues then i have to think
it might not be us it might be you it
might be men
it might be men now i've often talked
about the pacification of america
and how men are no longer men i talked
to my mom about this a lot and she says
well maybe it's just the guys in texas
maybe it's just the guys in los
angeles it is not just the guys in los
angeles nashville dallas and it's not
they're not any better in the midwest
they quite frankly i think they're trash
all over this country in the age range
of about
20 to i think about 55 maybe even 60.
a lot of men are trash a lot of men
don't know how to treat women a lot of
men
don't know how to really quite frankly
pull their heads out of the sand and pay
attention so
i am going to help you tommy also said
reading now from
amanda presley giacomo's daily wire
article about it she also said
i'm not a feminist so please don't take
this as a feminist rant
laryn interjected after imploring men to
follow up with plans instead of merely
texting women
i love men i think men are great i think
men have failed themselves and they
failed us
and i'm trying to help you out because i
love men i think they're great they're
just failures that's all
i they're great but they're failures
that's all i'm trying to tell you
they're great failures they're great at
failing anyway um
she says and i'm just trying to help you
out because i think there are a lot of
really great guys out there who need a
little help
and i don't think there are a lot of
women uh that are stepping up and saying
these things
this isn't patronizing at all is it i
think you're fantastic i just think you
need a little help that's all you need
help from me
a 27 year old blonde woman
so uh continuing she says so i'm going
to go ahead and say them because
they need to be said i am really so sick
of my friends having to deal with trash
men i'm tired of dealing with trash men
the pundit also told men to value value
and not quote mix in people like me and
my friends
who have something going on with your
other girls that have nothing going on
don't mix us in with the
f tatianas is that is that a what is
that
t-h-o-t-i-n-a-s
is that a thing the kids are saying now
i don't know what that means
don't mix us in with the thought
thatianas
anyway um and then she goes on from
there okay
now it goes without saying that
if a man were to ever make a video
claiming
that most women between the ages of 20
and 60 are
trash it would be roundly condemned as
insanely sexist
and he would be written off as a bitter
lonely virginal incel that that's what
would happen we all know that
um women have a a better chance of
getting away with something like this
now
at least the consequences aren't as
severe tommy is sustaining quite a bit
of criticism for this and rightly so but
it's not the same as it would be
if her name was you know thomas or her
name was spelled t-o-o-m-m-y instead of
with an i
uh it'd be a totally different ballgame
we all know that now yes it's true that
men
have issues in this culture it's true
that
that
men many men are not living up to their
calling as men
are not fulfilling their masculine
duties it's true that that some men
are soft and pathetic and rather wimpy
it's true that some men would rather lay
around the house all day playing video
games then actually go out and live a
real
active assertive life all of that is
true
and you could argue that all tommy was
doing was pointing these things out but
there are two problems
number one first problem is this
we get it okay we really do
we all know this stuff about men we've
heard it a million times
men are lectured constantly everywhere
by everyone
always men are lectured at in school
at work in in their homes
on tv at church you'll notice speaking
of church
um and i'm certainly not the first
person to have noticed this that
mother's day sermons at church are
usually about how wonderful and amazing
and un
underappreciated mothers are while
father's day sermons at churches
are often focused on how men need to
step up and do a better job
okay and that's the dynamic in the
culture that we get
so we get it we've heard it that doesn't
mean we never need to hear it again
or that it never needs to be said again
but it does mean that if all you have to
offer is the same old tired lecture with
not
any without any you know additional
insight
um with with nothing unique to to add
into it then
then just don't bother save your breath
save your energy
because once again we've heard it we
know
we get it i promise you
number two women are not innocent in
this
they are they aren't even more innocent
than men it's more than just
oh women have faults too notes women are
just as bad
they're just as guilty they're just as
culpable
okay you want gender equality right well
here it is
enjoy gender equality means that
if there's a problem in you know in
relations between men and women
you don't get to just assume that it's
all a man's fault
because when you do that what you're
essentially saying is that
you know this is all entirely up to the
men to the man
i mean he has the lead and uh and you
know he's in charge
and so if things go sideways it's gonna
be his fault
that's the only way the only way you
could put all the blame on men
is by saying that men are totally in
charge and should be
and so that whenever things don't work
out it's going to be their fault
but something tells me that that's not
tommy's perspective
um something tells me that
tommy is not someone who would say that
women should always be submitting to the
leadership of men
it could be wrong but i'm guessing
that's not her position
and if it's not your position then you
don't get to put all the blame on men or
even most of the blame on men
or even 51 of the blame women it is 50
50
because guess what i know you want to
talk about anecdotal evidence here
i know plenty of great guys who've had
trouble finding
women trouble finding women who are not
to use
tommy's phrase trash and do you know why
they've had trouble
well because in some cases they don't
make a lot of money or
you know they've got you know they're
employed they
they have good jobs they just they don't
make tons of money
or you know maybe they don't necessarily
look like calvin klein models
but they're good men hard-working men
loyal intelligent all of that
sometimes i know men like this i think
we all do
they've had trouble finding a woman
because in their experience
women will find superficial and
materialistic reasons to turn away men
who definitely are not in any
way trash so this is a knife that cup
cuts both ways and here's the thing
if you're having trouble finding a match
for you
and if you find that everyone you come
across is trash
and that there's a fatal flaw with every
member of the opposite sex that you've
ever encountered
then yes it could be that you have
horrible luck it could be woe is you
you're a victim this is all everybody
else's fault and not your own that's
possible
you could keep keep getting stuck with
duds through no fault of your own you
could keep reaching your hand into the
barrel of apples and taking out a rotten
one by accident maybe sure
but it's quite possible and i would say
even likely
and in fact quite probable that the
problem is at least
partially you it's
it's quite likely that some of those men
who you dismissed as trash
actually aren't trash but you toss them
aside
as trash because they fail to meet your
expectations in some
relatively unimportant area you might
even say you toss them aside as trash
for trashy reasons it's quite possible
that many of the
of the trash men actually are trash but
there's something about you and your
personality
that attracts those kinds of people
those are all possibilities too
and so if i was in this spot
and which i'm not and believe me here's
the other here's the other stipulation
i'll make is that anyone who's single
man or woman
in in this culture god be with you
uh i i have nothing but sympathy for you
and i thank god every day that i'm not
okay i couldn't be happier to be married
so um but even so
if if i was in that spot
and i found that uh you know i'm looking
for a woman but
every woman i meet is is
horrible and selfish and materialistic
and a bimbo and all this stuff
then i'm going to start to think to
myself you know i i i think there's
going to be a moment where i really stop
and i think
um what am i doing wrong here
maybe everyone else is doing something
wrong it's possible
but then it's weird because i look
around and i see that there
are plenty of people who manage to find
other good people and they have good
relationships
that does exist there are plenty of
married people in this country even
young married people who have good
marriages
that does exist it's it's not it's it's
not a it's not a myth it's not an urban
legend it exists
i i'm telling you i can tell you from
experience it exists
so i think i would look at that and i
would say hmm
okay so it is possible to find a good
person
plenty of other people have done it
and yet i can't why is that
i could be a victim of the universe yeah
that's true the universe is picking on
me
i don't know maybe jeez maybe there's
something about me that just attracts
these types
am i am i attractive to horrible people
or or or do i
am i someone who doesn't even can't even
identify a good virtuous person because
i'm so lacking in virtue myself
and so i have possibly thrown out a lot
of virtuous people
because i didn't recognize them for the
virtues they had i mean so these these
are all these are these are this is a
self analysis that i would
undergo and i guess that would be my
here's my psa that i'm going to throw
out there to
not just women men and women you know if
you're having problems in this regard
rather than blaming everybody else and
giving tips and advice
to other people by the way i always love
it when when
people who have not had a successful
relationship
give relationship advice okay that's
like
if you're training someone on a
on a how to fly but every plane that
you've ever
piloted has crashed it's like
if i'm a rookie pilot looking for some
advice i'm probably not going to go to
you
but in any case rather than going and
giving advice and all of that
and blaming everyone maybe do a little
bit of a self-analysis
and uh the speech and lecture you want
to give
maybe go into your bathroom and give
that lecture into the mirror
because i think that's probably the
number one person that needs to hear it
and uh for that reason tommy laren is
canceled we'll leave it there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
godspeed
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
joe biden forgets about his cognitive
decline billionaire oprah winfrey tells
poor white people that they have a whole
lot of privilege
and millard fillmore gets canceled 170
years
after the compromise of 1850. shocking
shocking stuff plus the mailbag
check it out on the michael knowles show